[Musica]
[Applauso]
john cage utilizza la pausa per fermare
il momento che nel caso di un direttore
d'orchestra è la cosa più importante che
sta facendo in quel momento la
conduzione di una sinfonia viviamo in
tempi in cui i manager sono super
impegnati non riescono a gestire loro
tempo e si giustificano con scuse tipo
il dottore riunione
oppure siamo sotto budget riparliamone
fra quattro mesi
quel tipo di persone che quando andate
da loro con qualcosa di davvero
importante e vitale per voi guardano
fisso lo schermo del computer fanno sì
sì con la testa ma non vi stanno
ascoltando un modo di lavorare con le
persone che pensavo appartenesse più
alla mia generazione fatta di manager
che non prendono mai delle pause che non
vanno mai in ferie che mandano email a
tutte le ore del giorno e della notte in
come conoscenza mille persone affamati
di obiettivi e di un'apparenza che gli
sta succhiando ogni minuto del loro
tempo invece mi sto accorgendo che
stiamo affidando alle parole la
responsabilità di continuare a
succhiarsi il tempo vitale semplicemente
le stiamo aggiornando innovation digital
transformation change management e
racconta una storia
il tempo è scandito da questo orologio
che posizionato su una frase ancora non
molto chiara per andrea che da qualche
mese sta lavorando per una piccola
azienda innovativa
aggiungerei anche leader di mercato per
non farci mancare niente
l'orologio è fisso sulla stessa ora da
quando andrea in ufficio probabilmente
dipende dalle batterie ma nessuno sembra
farci troppo caso in un ambiente così
smart dove anche le piante sono di
plastica e dove i push
i biliardini sono arrivati prima della
carta igienica e del sapone per le mani
andrea cerca di scrollarsi di dosso un
po tutto il frastuono intorno a lui de
continua notifiche i colleghi che
parlano ad alta voce telefonate che
arrivano continuamente
all'inizio sembrava anche e divertente
però dopo un poco trendy conto che
questo tipo di di luoghi non sono
esattamente quelli preposti né a
conservare la privacy né a tessere delle
relazioni né tantomeno a generare
creatività fra l'altro una ricerca
finanziata da una grossa compagnia di
arredamento per ufficio ha fatto notare
come in ottantasei minuti ogni giorno di
distrazione ambientali non solo la
produttività cala del 18 per cento ma
aumenta del 36 per cento il malessere
psicofisico dei dipendenti e una
domenica sera andrea in ufficio con i
suoi colleghi la prima volta era un
cliente che ha chiesto una variazione la
seconda volta è slittata una commessa ha
fatto sta che il terzo weekend di
seguito che andrea i suoi colleghi lo
passano in ufficio
naturalmente senza un euro in più in
busta paga
eppure michele il ceo dell'azienda
è un ragazzo di 38 anni cammina scalzo
per l'ufficio per sentirsi tutt'uno con
il suo ambiente
arriva in ufficio in bicicletta quasi
sempre tranne quando piove in quel caso
arriva con un cayenne appena laureato
con in aiuto il suo papà ha aperto
questa azienda senza avere di fatto
un'esperienza nel settore
in realtà nessuna esperienza in nessun
settore ma questo non è importante
perché michele non è che lo vediamo
tanto spesso in ufficio e spesso
impegnato in lectio magistralis presidia
le social media week
spesso e volentieri rilascio interviste
a giornalisti affamati di casi di
successo a cui racconta un po la sua
storia d amore passione people first
segui i tuoi sogni sono i suoi slogan
più caratteristici ma quello che proprio
fa spellare le mani ai giovani
industriali e quando dice quella frase
non sarà lavorando 40 ore alla settimana
che cambieremo il mondo
lì c'è proprio la standing ovation
giovani imprenditori che dovrebbero
essere diversi dai loro padri
e invece ricordano tristemente quel
manager recentemente scomparso che
facendo visita alle fabbriche ad agosto
non si riusciva a capacitare che i suoi
operai avessero preso qualche giorno di
ferie
infine da che cosa aveva detto qualche
settimana fa
andrea era uscito una ventina di minuti
più tardi rispetto all'orario concordato
i manager non c'erano il lavoro era
finito non c'era più nessun tasca aperto
aveva deciso di prendere un autobus che
lo portasse a casa un orario decente
peccato che a casa trova una mail di
michele che gli dice di essere
estremamente deluso dal suo
comportamento
il giorno dopo con un bel braccio
intorno al collo girando per il
corridoio dell'ufficio come se fosse un
confessionale gli aveva detto che il suo
sacrificio era importante per il bene di
tutto il gruppo a che tutti e stavano
cercando di realizzare qualche cosa di
importante un comportamento come il suo
sicuramente aveva tradito la fiducia di
tutti i suoi colleghi ecco la mia
generazione con la pnl con i team
building ha fatto veramente nei casini
memorabili ma quando sento o ragazzo
così giovane dire una frase di questo
genere a me vengono in mente quei
percorsi sui carboni ardenti un po degli
anni 80 non so se avete presente
naturalmente
versione industry 4.0 in questo caso i
colleghi di andrea sono tutti ragazzi
molto talentuosi tecnicamente perfetti
peccato quel fastidiosissimo positivismo
tipico dello start apparo che ti fa
sembrare tutto che vada bene anche
quando niente va bene e che tutto si
possa risolvere con un bel batti cinque
è una frase buttata lì quando arrivano
le pizze sono tutti entusiasti stanno
sistemando i puffi i tavolini per la
scena e naturalmente si stanno scattando
qualche sel fico l'immancabile hashtag
isle of my job
il ragazzo delle pizze è arrivato
puntualissimo alle 20 come aveva
previsto l'app di proprietario una
multinazionale che fattura svariati
milioni di euro l'ora
ma che non ha la possibilità o la
volontà di assumere sue riders né
tantomeno di dare loro i diritti
fondamentali di qualsiasi lavoratore per
qualsiasi lavoro d'altra parte nelle
startup lavorano prevalentemente ragazzi
dediti alle tecnologie e al digitale
ragazzi molto giovani che stanno vivendo
in un momento estremamente complesso
dove una forte crisi di valori c'è
effettivamente una crisi economica
importante c'è una mancanza di lavoro
effettivo da quando il digitale è
entrato prepotentemente anche nelle
pieghe del terziario italiano
i millennio sono diventati l'obiettivo
perfetto a cui far credere che il lavoro
non è qualcosa che fai ma è tutto quello
che hai e soprattutto che tu come
persona viene valorizzata per gli
obiettivi e per i risultati e non per la
persona che sei
andrea non ci sta il suo zaino è rivolto
sotto un sotto una delle scrivanie e
dalla task aperta esce un cane del che
gli ricorda che almeno sette mesi che
non riesce a riprendere in mano un libro
che aveva iniziato prende la giacca
dallo schienale fa per andare dall'altra
parte della stanza michele dice scusa
dove stai andando non è ancora finito
tutto a posto
vado a casa no ma fai facciamo un
qualche altra maniera la prenditi una
pausa magari sai che cosa domani mattina
arriva in ufficio un pochino prima così
chiudiamo la commessa ma andrea ha già
imboccato il corridoio sente perché
sotto i suoi piedi in finto tech sulle
pareti scorrono le frasi di guru
americani e qualche pupazzo preso
negli anni ottanta passa di fronte alla
reception si ferma di fronte all'immensa
porta in entrata il logo dell'azienda si
spezza in due mentre la porta a vetri si
apre una bella aria frizzante e gli
colpisce nella 10 e andrea finalmente
felice felice di odiare i lunedì grazie
c'è una bonus track piccolo premotoria
per imprenditori innovativi
assumete persone migliori di voi le
aziende non hanno idee ce le hanno le
persone fermate il tempo per permettere
alle persone di conoscere fra di loro
le aziende che funzionano meglio sono
quelle che hanno il turnover più basso
in cui le persone conoscendosi si fidano
gli uni degli altri
vietate le persone di portarsi caffè la
scrivania allungato i tempi di
permanenza le macchinette del caffè il
cemento è più importante dei mattoni i
talenti non sono mai delle superstar non
sono quelle con il voto più alto che
faranno cadere più lunghe ma quelli
bravi a collaborare
grazie
[Applauso]